we're on problem 207 if n is equal to 4p
n is equal to 4 P where pre is a where P
is a prime number greater than 2 so PE
is prime and it's greater than 2 how
many different positive even divisors
does n have including n so how many
numbers how many integers go into N or
go into 4p well definitely 4 goes into
it right because this is going to be a
multiple of 4 and then anything that
goes into 4 will also go into it so 2
goes into it 2 is also a divisor P would
go into it right and are there any other
numbers that go into P well no P is
prime well you know one goes into P but
they wanted to know let's see they want
to know the different positive even
divisors so the positive we're just
dealing in the positive world that just
lets us know this isn't some trick
question where we have to count negative
numbers but they want even divisors so
first of all 1 is not even so that can't
be it the second question is P even well
by definition if P was even and if it's
greater than 2 it would be divisible by
2 so it wouldn't be able to be prime but
they tell us that P is prime and P is
prime and it's greater than 2 so it
can't be divisible by 2 so it has to be
odd so this is also not an even divisor
so there's only two even divisors 4 and
2 so the answer is to a problem 208 208
s is a set containing 9 different
numbers so S has 9 numbers T is a set
containing 8 numbers T contains 8
numbers all of which are members of s ok
which of the following statements cannot
be true the mean of s is equal to the
mean of T so let's think about this a
little bit let's say so choice a that
their averages are equal to each other
let's just say that set set s is equal
to 1 through 9 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and so
what would it mean
be well it's mean if you average all of
these numbers if you have one in tenth
nine you get five you have verse two and
eight to get five you have verse three
and seven you get 5y average four and
six you get five your average five you
get five
so the average is five right so what if
what if so this is s and what if T were
this what if T were just this right here
let me label that that's T and that's
not seven that's T and then s is
everything so it's T plus the five so
the average of all the numbers in T if
your average one two three four six
seven eight nine your average is going
to be five right let me think about the
average of four and six is five average
of three and seven five I think you get
the idea you can work it out if you like
and then if you were to if you were to
take set s which is all of these numbers
plus the number five if you add five to
a set of numbers whose average is five
the average is still going to be five so
a definitely works B the median of s is
equal to the median of T well once again
this that's true what this said we this
is this is a good set to work with it
proves everything we need to prove
what's the median of T it's the middle
number and T there's eight numbers so
you have to average the middle two
numbers so if you average the middle two
numbers and T 4 and 6 you get five so
five is median of T and then what's the
median of s well now s includes the five
so you can put all of these numbers in
order and so five is the middle number
so five is also the median of S choice C
so both of these can happen a or B which
I see the range of s is equal to the
range of T so the range of a set is just
the difference between the highest and
lowest number and then the range range
of S is equal to what the highest number
and S is nine the lowest numbered and S
is one so that equals nine minus one
which is equal to eight
what's the range of T well the highest
number and T is nine the lowest number
is one nine minus one is equal to eight
so this one can definitely be true
statement D
the mean of s is greater than the mean
of T well sure instead of this being a
five what if this was what if this was a
50 right now all of a sudden you know
the average of T would still be five but
if you throw this 50 in there for ass
your average is going to go well good
bit above five so the statement D could
definitely work if you just make that
extra number that's an S a lot larger
number and then statement a which I'm
guessing is the choice that cannot be
true because we could figure out a case
for all of a through D the range of S is
less than the range of T the range of
lat s so the range is the difference
between the highest and the lowest right
so the range I mean no matter what the
range of S has to be at least as large
as the range of T think about it in this
case the law you know the range of T is
9 minus 1 which is 8 right so under you
you could make the range of s larger if
you used fifty-fifty was the extra
number then the range is 50 minus 1 but
considering that all of these numbers in
T are also in s the difference between
the highest number in in T and the
lowest number in T has to be less than
or less than or equal to the range of s
so the they're saying that the reducing
the opposite of the range of s is less
than the range of T and we know this
cannot be true because T is a subset of
s so choice is e next problem took me
more time than I wanted to 209 how many
different positive integers are factors
of 441 well they are essentially just at
factoring it well C is this this should
be divisible by let's see 4 plus 4 is 8
plus 1 is 9 so this should be divisible
by 3 so 3 goes into 441 1 times 3 is 1
now the 4 goes into 4 times 12 and then
you get 21 27 right so you get it 3
times 147 3 and 147 and then 3 should
also go into this because 1 plus 4 plus
7 is 12 which is divisible by 3 so 3
goes into 147 147 you go 4 times 12 27
49 times so so let's just do a prime
factorization of 441 you get 3 and 147
147 factors into 3 and 27 which then
factors into 3 & 9 which then factors
into 3 & 3 okay so I didn't realize but
this is a lame that this is the same
thing as 3 to the fit is that right 3
times is that 3 goes into 140 sorry I
made a mistake 3 let me redo this 3 goes
into 147 not 27 times 49 times so then
this is if you do prime factorization a
7 & a 7
alright I was about to say 441 isn't 3
to the 5th power so let's let's write
that down here so 4 for W in a different
color so I'm gonna be confusing so 441
is equal to 3 times 3 times 7 times 7
right so if they want to know how many
different positive integers are factors
so all you have to think about is how
many positive integers can i construct
with threes with two threes and two
sevens so let's just list them three
definitely works three times three will
definitely work what's going to order
seven will definitely work three times
three will work that's 9 3 times 7 would
work 21 3 times 3 times 49 will work
right 3 times 7 times 7 so 3 times 49
will work which was actually 147
1:47 works then nine times seven would
work which is 63 right nine times seven
and then you have nine times seven times
seven so that's essentially 441 let me
make sure I haven't missed any
combinations right you have one three
and one seven so you have a three and a
seven you have a three and two sevens
you have two threes and a seven two
threes and a seven and then you could
have two threes two threes and two
sevens and then of course you have the
three and the seven so I have one two
three four five six numbers here I got
one two three what am I missing here so
I got a three seven oh of course I'm
actually missing the three times the
three and I'm missing the seven times
the seven so it's one two three four
five six seven eight factors of which
441 and that's not one of the choices
that's not one of the choices so I'm
clearly how many different positives oh
and of course the number one so how many
does that come to one two three four
five six seven eight nine numbers and so
that is d there must be a faster way of
doing that I'll let you think about that
one anyway see you in the next video